so we've had updates like that every
night for several weeks now we've done
our best to keep you up to date on what
is happening in this pandemic but in
past few days the truth has seemed like
a swiftly moving target some of the big
numbers have been changing almost
day-by-day others appear to contradict
each other in many other cases the
information just isn't complete yet and
won't be for a while it's all happening
very very fast but at this point a
couple of trends are coming into focus
first of them an awful lot of people are
getting sick from this illness tens of
thousands of new infections every day
some of them are dying it's horrifying
to watch but there's also a glint of
brightness on the horizon a forecast
that many of us did not expect estimates
the final death toll have been revised
dramatically downward dr. Tony Fauci
acknowledged as much today do you think
the number of fatalities in this country
will be significantly lower than the
hundred thousand to two hundred forty
thousand first projected I do I believe
we are gonna see a downturn in that and
it looks more like the 60,000 than the
hundreds of two hundred thousand but
having said that we better be careful
that we don't say okay we're doing so
well we could pull back 60,000 deaths
that's a very big number and if someone
you love is among them it's everything
at the same time it is far fewer than
many expected it is a much lower number
and we want to be as honest as we can
about this then we predicted on this
show for example this is one of those
cases when we are grateful to be wrong
and not just wrong about the death toll
the number of infected patients who need
to be hospitalized has also been way
below early estimates we feared that a
massive wave of desperate people
struggling to breathe would overwhelm
our hospitals and break our health care
system that was the primary concern but
so far it hasn't happened instead
something completely unexpected appears
to be taking place across the country
health care workers are being let go or
furloughed elective procedures have been
canceled that means there aren't
patients for them to care for hospitals
are running short on cash in Oklahoma
City an entire Hospital has been closed
except for its emergency room almost
everywhere except the New York metro
area Detroit and New Orleans Hoss
many of them are sitting half empty or
empty thanks to a lockdown meant to ease
pressure on hospitals that's a story
none of us expected to see it's all
pretty shocking given what we expected
but the weirdest thing of all is how
little attention this is all getting in
a crisis nothing is more important than
staying connected to reality facts
change very fast and it's easy to miss
them and instead get trapped in a
storyline that you created weeks or
months before that's especially a
temptation in the news business but it's
how terrible decisions get made the
people making those decisions don't look
up long enough to notice that their
assumptions were wrong something like
that may be happening now in some cases
that people paid to bring you the very
latest news seem utterly ignorant of
what is actually happening and they
deeply resent any attempt to bring them
up to speed watch this MSNBC newsreader
scold anyone who dares suggest that
observable reality has changed in any
way from two weeks ago let's make
something clear open for business is a
sentiment it's a sign it's not real life
this isn't a snow day we're not going to
decide a week from now or three weeks
not all right everybody trot back to
work so when you look at the
unemployment number it's upsetting and
it's jarring but it also means that
Americans are going home which is what
we need them to do and think about it if
he's mentioning this to people in the AG
community if you run a farm you cannot
run the risk that people you have out
there working have the virus they're
spreading it to someone else this is
very serious business this is a perfect
example of where the stock market and
real life and the real economy are two
very different things
so 17 million people unemployed is
actually a positive sign they're telling
you it means Americans are doing quote
what we need to do if you find yourself
saying something like that out loud
pause for a moment and listen to your
own words it means you've lost
perspective
in this specific case we should give
everyone the benefit of the doubt
Americans are tired and fearful they're
frayed from weeks of uncertainty and
sadness but that does not eliminate our
obligation to think as clearly as we can
because at some point we're going to
have to
pivot from our current lockdown to
whatever comes next and now is the time
to figure out what that means it's not
enough to harangue the public about how
they're immoral somehow if they don't
like being shut inside all day that's
the easy path right now and not
surprisingly it's what a lot of our
politicians are doing but the country
deserves more obviously we ought to be
working hard to determine which parts of
American life can return to normal which
cannot and when how do you move a nation
of 320 million people from isolation and
joblessness back to something better
you don't hear many people talking about
that right now
in any detail but you should be so we're
gonna start going forward we hope to be
a forum for all good ideas on how to
bring America back and buy good ideas we
mean sensible safe incremental solutions
this is a complex moment you should be
aware of anyone who claims to be able to
fix it with a slogan that is impossible
other country is already well down this
road per capita Austria has been
affected in very much the same way by
coronavirus as we have here next week
the Austrian government will allow most
small businesses to reopen hair salons
and shopping malls will follow in early
May than restaurants and hotels the
Austrians are being careful about this
and of course they should be stores are
being told to limit how many patrons
come inside at once where a masks inside
grocery stores and public transportation
will be mandatory travel in or out of
Austria will be sharply restricted
probably for some time now America is
not Austria we can't copy every move the
Austrians make and expect the same
results but we can watch carefully and
learn from what they're doing and what
other countries have done and we should
do that we're gonna continue to do that
starting right now